things happen to you like you're is it
your house in near dover
oh yes yes
i'm glad you brought that up because i
do rent my house
if you're interested to other people
and it's the nearest house to france
which is very important in this story
and it's 425 pounds a week and it sleeps
it sleeps um six people so for seven
nights
yes yes anyway
one one day i got a call from the police
and they said um are you the owner of
the gun emplacement and i said yes
they said are you aware that it's been
used
as a drop for
criminals
to get rid of their drugs or you know
it's a drug drop i believe that's the
yes the phrase
and um i said well of course i didn't
know what do you mean and they said well
people have rented it they were a gang a
gang
from uh liverpool
and um
they they took my house
and they dropped the drugs
in the bay or they and there was a
helicopter that came on the roof it's a
flat roof yes
and they they had cocaine they had
something like 13 million
pounds
jesus christ
of cocaine
no i don't
well of course i was horrified because i
didn't know i mean i don't have anything
to do with the people that rent it you
just take the money you know yeah
and i was i well i could get more for it
because it's really lovely
was when it was reported of course in
the daily mail
um
all the people online
said oh she must be in it you know she's
part of the gag
they were calling me miriam escobar
[Applause]
proper western i mean we see tom hanks
guntoten which we rarely see
well i don't have i don't wear one i am
given one later on so it's not like you
know i'm not doing the root and tooting
kind of thing
but i i i i ride a horse
and um i drive a wagon and i've
discovered so i'm not a i'm not a writer
per se but i did learn i i had a
fabulous
got to know a fabulous horp named wimpy
who was my horse wimpy was my host
and um
i don't know if anybody here is has
ridden a lot or made a western emily has
a couple of westerns under her belt as i
recall emily my darling how are you how
are you wonderful to see you
see
you know i'm about to do a western like
next january i'm doing a six-part
western and we were just discussing how
allergic i am to horses and i do every
scene with a horse you know i'm going to
be antihistamined up to my eyeball
do you have to
kiss the horse
isn't that what happens in western to
make out
which you sort of have to do because i
have a feeling that horses honestly they
would much rather live in a world
without human beings climbing on top of
them and they know the moment you climb
on their back that you're terrible at
riding like i mean i've been learning
right now i'm i'm in london now
rehearsing for it and i go riding three
times a week and every time they give me
a different horse to see you know how
you fare oh with one that's more
spoilery or one that's less of a ferrari
and i got on one the other day called
rusty oh my god they almost took off
with me it was terrifying
i couldn't walk the next day rusty did
me in
[Laughter]
rusty did her in rusty
wow
is that the name of the film
[Applause]
there's this isn't no of course this
isn't this water but so there are you
know there are set twos you have some
tetchy moments and words and obviously
you can kill him but
can we talk about the sex scene it's one
of the best sex scenes i've seen in
forever oh that's sexy who put that
together yo seriously
you
no it's not and it's not what i'm saying
it's not like they're kind of like
prancing around naked it's just it's a
really
clever
who who put did you guys put that
together did ricky scott put it together
no we had nothing to do with that
excuse me i'm just trying to cover my
universe
and of course it's not just you in it
other screen legends jeremy
jeremy
jeremy was particular
he was great he was behind the camera
why are you having sex
this is a breakthrough role for you jack
because
an american accent
yes yes i was doing an american accent
what in that clip yes olivia
you see
what a lot of actors do when they do an
american accent
is they tend to just go for like one
region of america and they commit to a
single american accent i decided with
this role that i would take senator
around all 50 states
sometimes in the same scene i thought
why just do one when you can show off
the mall
i would start the scene talking like i
was from new york and then all of a
sudden i'm suddenly speaking like i'm a
cali girl and by the end of the scene
they're stopping me because it sounds
like i'm from the dukes of hazzard
i'm all over the place but i thought you
know just show off your skills or a
bartender and i just love the idea you
would be such a good bartender marco
thank you generous don't you know he'd
do a generous pour he would always ask
for awkwardness i i i would do a
generation
mostly because people would be like come
on man
really
but no but didn't you had your own
cocktail i had the margarita
and what are you doing with ruffalo but
no margarita but i ended up having uh
you know i'd start early and i'd had my
my thursday night crowd yeah partially
because and i'm sorry sean mcpherson
wherever you are
i gave away a lot of free drinks
it wasn't a great quality in a bartender
but you were good dealing with with uh
drunk customers which is i had to deal
with a lot of drunk people yes
and um sometimes they were not very nice
no
there'd be nights where i'd be up to my
eyeballs and a-holes
um i'm saying nothing
can i keep going i don't know what's
going to mean
wait what what did i say nothing
is that a spoiler
so no wasn't there a guy who wanted uh
wasn't there a drunkard oh i get it yeah
wasn't there a drunk guy it wasn't that
kind of bar
was there a drunk guy who wanted a
sambuca yes there was okay tell us about
him so occasionally um you would get
someone who was so obnoxious and uh it
was the end of the night and this guy
came in
and he's like all right and he was
wasted and he was such an a-hole
and uh he's like i want a zambooka
i'm like come on man
you you're doing okay
you're like give me a zambucha
and
did you hit his knee like that
[Music]
i'm like okay so i pour on the sambuca
light it
i'm not gonna let you drink man
i don't like drinks okay you want to let
your drink you let you drink yourself
light it
okay
i light the drink he takes it
and it goes all over his face
dripping down his face blue flames
everywhere
and i'm trying not to laugh
and he
beats the hell out of himself to get it
out
give me another
sure
thing
want me to light it for you
yes
same thing
[Applause]
it was one of the greatest nights
i sort of like him for having another
one
i love him he walked out with like uh
like a a a flaming red goatee
that brings back a really painful memory
it was you know
i was like 12
13. i i
i was lit i was a late bloomer but i had
a premature mustache
like i had hair there and nowhere else
right uh i mean my head of course
and uh and i was begging my dad because
kids were making fun of me like hey your
stash swimmer you must you know and so i
was begging my dad hey can i please
shave and my dad was like you're too
young to shave i'm sorry but i was
i took matters into my own hand and i
borrowed some of my sister's nair oh no
and for those of you who don't know it's
like a chemical hair removal we got an
immaculate immaculate okay so i put it
on my lip but i left it on too long
so i had a burn mark
just
you know i had to then go to school and
everyone knew i had tried to take my
hair up and they're like what the
so all these other names so i'm sorry to
bring up we live that
trauma but i want to share that
very good
i heard you talking somewhere
how your height difference makes those
stunts more complicated thank you graeme
i didn't say it didn't dance did it
now that is a good story it's like a
story well you see there's there's a
particular stun i don't know if it's in
this but there's a you know he
spider-man swings us on top of a bridge
and he places me there and that's the
bridge yeah that's the bridge we
eventually jump off of that i'm
screaming yeah um
so
he's supposed to gently you know rest mj
on the bridge and walk away from her
it because of our height difference i
obviously if we're on the same like
point
we were attached i would land before him
my feet obviously hit the ground before
he does
so
what would happen
well
there's like it's called a bottom mark
isn't it and the bottom mark is to
basically it's a thing that they do in
stunts that is basically designed to
stop you shattering your kneecaps oh
yeah so zendaya would land and i'm the
superhero i'm supposed to look cool
and she would land and then i would sort
of land like this and my feet would
swing from underneath me and then she
would catch me
you're actually very very lovely about
you were like oh my gosh thank you
it's so nice to be caught for a change
[Music]
you